thank you very
much for this opportunity and I have to
say that I do
admire Nexus
Institute what you do and how much you
delivered such strong messages not just
for Europe but for
Humanity here at Nexus 20 years ago Josh
Tiner gave an important speech about the
idea of Europe
and he said Europe is made up of Cafe
this extend from pes's favorite Cafe in
Lisbon to the OD Cafe is haunted by
Isaac Babel's gangsters and I fully
believe I very often
mention this moment of China and I fully
believe in this Spirit of Cafe as
said which thrives in our great
continent from lisabon to Essa because
Cafe are clothed where where people are
bombed and Cafe whereare is a place
where you can have controversies
discussions you can share dis agreements
but at the very
end you
dream all Europe is made of
dreams but actual dreamers are very
pragmatic otherwise they finish with the
dreams of the
others I'm a dreamer and
idealistic but I don't want my
dreams to be dreamed
in all people's
language I want our music to be the one
to be played everywhere de Jordi I want
our literature to be precisely this
permanent discussion between the
different capitals of our continent was
one of the characteristics is
precisely to have so many languages and
and to be in a certain way driven by
this permanent
translation I want our model of
complexity Unity through
respect and
diversity to be the one to be preserved
this is why we have to reset this
economic Doctrine this is why European
sovereignty is not just a concept or
fantasy but it's absolutely in a
dangerous world
a
necessity to live dream for ourselves as
Europeans thank
you